Hi, my name's
Justin Koh, and I'm
an engineer on the
Android Wear team.
Let's look at how
your app can let users
provide voice input to
notification actions
with Android Wear.
Before we jump in,
make sure you've
checked out the previous
video on the basics
for developing for Android
Wear, including how to optimize
your notifications
for the wrist.
And remember to check
out developer.android.com
where you can sign up for
the developer preview,
and browse the documentation.
So imagine we've built
a messaging app that
has a reply action in new
message notifications.
Something like this.
When a user presses reply
on a phone or tablet,
you would take them to a screen
that would let them compose
and send a reply, like this.
If we don't optimize this
notification for the wrist,
pressing the reply action
on an Android Wear device
would simply open the
Reply screen on your phone.
But we can do better.
With the remote input feature
of the Android Wear API,
we can hint Android Wear
devices that our app can accept
free form voice input in
response to the notification.
So here's what that looks like.
Let's show the
notification again,
and reply from our
Android Wear device.
The user gets
presented with a voice
prompt along with a
custom hint, in this case,
reply to Bugdroid.
They can then speak a reply
like, I'll be right there,
and after confirming, the
reply text is sent to the app.
The key here is that the app
can skip the phone UI entirely,
simply sending off the reply
text in the background.
Let's look at the code to
build such a notification.
First, we use the standard
NotificationCompat Builder
to create the notification.
We'll omit the reply action for
now, since we'll add it later.
Next, we'll build the reply
actions, PendingIntent.
This intent will be started
when the user presses the Reply
button on the phone.
Note that the intent
should be for an activity,
because otherwise
pressing the action won't
close the notification shade.
Finally, we use the remote
input builder and action builder
classes to construct
an action that
will be capable of
receiving voice input.
Extra reply text tells Android
Wear the name of an intent
extra to add to the
reply intent when
a voice response was provided.
And then we simply need to wrap
our NotificationCompat builder
in a wearable
notification builder.
That's it!
To handle voice replies
in your reply activity,
simply check if the extra
you specified earlier
has any content.
If it does, you know that the
user responded with their voice
from their Android Wear
device and you can simply
send the response and finish
the activity immediately.
Otherwise, show that activity
as you normally would.
And that's all there is to it.
The remote input feature
of the Android Wear API
can help you simplify
your user's lives,
by providing a seamless, wrist
optimized user experience
for responding to notifications.
There are even more APIs for
customizing notifications
for Android Wear devices.
So be sure to check out the
documentation and sample
code in the developer preview
on developer.android.com.
Thanks and happy coding.